hmm that was weird hey welcome to this
video meh lacunae who is that mikakunin
yeah I know I understand yeah he's in
scope yet right for the european club
cap check gather the flare I also this
is this guy finish yeah he is but he's
in sculpture for that event so make it
macedonia this was my rotation at the
start of the video game 92 i think only
night f5 or quincy form a ok night takes
a six of one acrylic a moose this slow
build-up could be really very
comfortable for black as some the night
only to israeli misplaced
okay inserting that cannot be really bad
now take the pawn yeah he's kind of
gambling on me not taking g5 and 96
before I think I can really take it
probably will be very very messy I'm not
sure that I want that achaea can be
taken place should be five hmm
should be five with a bit annoying okay
didn't do that so c6 also gives me a
square on c7 for my bishop is really
high rated their set a usual rating firm
you are much higher close that okay um
what to do yeah maybe bishop here
threatening bishop h2 is that really a
threat yeah I guess it is so takes that
yeah i think it's it's about equal this
position really and not that much going
on this we should be to a move here I
mean it's not a bad one but I can also
play like that maybe I could see five in
something with c5 possibly c4
let's go see five check see form ideas
that now is bishop is not really doing
much and I might have g6 and Bishop f5 I
think you will probably go be three yes
so cheeks yeah maybe on the c3 pawn
if you go see for ya 24 I thought maybe
query three years still okay if I'm okay
i can just going back as good I think it
takes Bishop takes comfortable yeah
taking whoopsie to know i think i can go
can promote Roxy to
is there anything going on here or is it
just completely equal probably it is
completely equal i can go Bishop c4 now
if I were saying so I probably shouldn't
do that
really that just looks risky taking a
day for so work c4 or how am I going to
do it probably I sir III know II takes
that so look here
check help I don't get any move here I
really must overlook stuff him you know
why am I not stopping this poem I'd see
eight
and 96 for some weird checkmate stuff
what Mike you can go 95 though 95 then
is going roop ki five right I don't get
anything
draw our third game drawn champ that's
probably the correct risotto it's never
really any big anything big going on yes
I have him chat leadership tea soon I
know well I like that idea but it seemed
that ultimately nothing nothing much
happened 95 maybe that's better really I
call queen bee seven yeah maybe the
engine gives me I have a powerful porn
maybe for some better activity but I
really think this is a draw yeah yeah i
was thinking Bishop c4 is is simple
ninety forever it's interesting didn't
think about the move hmm this is what
the engine checks is giving you very
sharp stuff Oh cherry shrimp stir chant
think this isn't this is ok i should
actually win a three wins
yeah that grabs the P so here we have
the draw let's uh that's stupid right in
97 also wins and I was playing before
wind like a madman I didn't really get
why but okay so this is when the night
has no squares and ultimately I can do
this am and pick it up huh yeah so this
some would have would have won the game
now anyway the draw is not not too
shabby thanks for watching